[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 114 am i
correct about that dr hein it is 114. it
is the 1 14th live stream
and uh i don't think we should kid them
everything is
haywire yeah if you've ever bailed your
own hay you know what that means it's
not good it's crazy but we're going to
get through this together so um welcome
yeah
indeed welcome we're going to talk um
we're going to continue to talk as we
began to talk last week about the
uh then it goes by a number of names the
truckers convoy uh truckers for freedom
the protests that are happening in
ottawa and across canada in fact um and
and a few other things but that at least
is where we're going to start today um
and um let's just let's get through the
announcements and logistics first
and and then jump right in
uh so
um
if you are watching on youtube the chat
is live on odyssey you can go there
you can ask questions for the q a that
will be live after we are done with this
uh first hour at
www.darkhorsesubmissions.com we make no
promises about getting to all the
questions in fact we never do get all to
all of the questions but we um get to as
many of them as we can
we encourage you to join our patreons it
helps us do what we're doing here last
week we had the private q a at my
patreon which is always a lot of fun
we have um we have some products at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org where you can
find direwolves and epic tabby and
digital brick burning and more
and i have i have come to begin to
recommend that you
go over to natural selections my sub
stack naturalselections.substance.com
uh where you can become a free
subscriber and get what is usually a
weekly essay into your inbox and then
paying subscribers get an audio read by
me
this week i posted six different six
different times uh four
guest posts uh two of which got a little
subsumed by the rest uh but uh they are
extraordinary as well two of them were
by a paramedic in wyoming jordan
hayes who has written
exemption letters to request
to request exemptions from the vaccine
mandates that are being handed down for
which he may
lose his job so i encourage you to read
to read both of those and then the other
two guest posts um are
uh are
from canada and i'm going to read a
little bit from both of them today they
are
extraordinary and um heartbreaking both
uh so i i do encour i will encourage
everyone to read them both in their
entirety but um we'll read some
some from both today um before that
though um
we want to thank our sponsors as always
uh so your support on patreon and your
support of our sponsors are both um are
both helping us do what we do and we are
grateful for all of them we are as we've
said many times very very choosy about
our sponsors our fabulous ad broker says
that you know we we reject more than we
accept and uh and he loves it and he
accepts that uh this is this is part of
why we are actually um able to to do
what we do that we actually do not
advertise for any products or companies
that we do not stand behind so without
further ado we have as usual three
sponsors this week
starting with vevo barefoot
our first sponsor
shoes made for feet most shoes are made
for someone's idea of what feet should
be and be constrained by and usually
that someone doesn't actually know feet
or what they can do vivo barefoot in
contrast nose feet the evil barefoot
isn't driven by fashion you can tell
because shoes aren't really all that
attractive i know i practically live in
them at this point when i'm not barefoot
but man oh man are these shoes a
revelation we love them they are beyond
comfortable and the tactile feedback
from the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution humans evolved to
walk move and run barefoot but modern
shoes
that are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted food
function
foot yeah food isn't really a word foot
function canadian
yeah um and are contributing to a health
crisis one in which people move less
than they might in part because their
shoes make their feet hurt
so vivo vevo wow i'm just gonna get all
the o's kind of canadian today okay
people barefoot shoes i don't know what
that was vivo barefoot shoes are
designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60 and a matter of
months just by walking around in them
the number of people wearing
vivobarefoots is growing it's an odd
little club easily recognizable because
the shoes are as i said a little unusual
looking once people start wearing these
shoes they don't seem to stop so go to
vivobarefoot.com
darkhorse to get an exclusive offer of
20 off additionally all new customers
get a 100 day free trial so you can see
if you love them as much as we do that
is v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash darkhorse all right um in
light of our
somewhat canadian themed uh podcast
today
vivobarefoot i am offering up a slogan
to them vivo barefoot go out in a boot
i don't know all right i i love their
hiking boots too yeah absolutely yeah
it's great stuff all right second
sponsor is all form a company that makes
absolutely terrific custom sofas what
makes the sofas terrific for a fraction
of the cost of traditional sofas you can
customize size layout fabric and color
they do arm chairs and love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional
sofa can you imagine it
and you can start small and buy more
seats later on without needing to go
to get a whole new sofa
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your home free and fast and assembly is
easy i can vouch for that
we have got a beautiful sectional
all-form sofa in whiskey leather it's
soft and supple warm unlike a lot of
leather we all pile on it to watch
movies some evenings it looks gorgeous
and is incredibly inviting and
comfortable a rare combination we like
it so much we're getting a second one
which i understand has been delivered
and i'm
looking forward to assembling it
also some listeners have asked if all
form holds up to pets why yes it does
the leather that all form uses is about
20 thicker than typical furniture
leather and shows no wear despite the
fact that both cats and dogs lie on the
couch many evenings and if you prefer
fabric all form has fabrics that are
three and a half times more durable than
the industry standard for heavy duty
fabrics
so their fabrics are going to hold up
really well with pets also
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
darkhorse all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com darkhorse that's a-l-l-f-o-r
dot com slash darkhorse
and
finally our final sponsor for today is
once again public goods
public goods was one of our very first
sponsors about nine months ago and we
are as pleased with them now as when we
first tried their products
public goods can simplify your life as a
one-stop shop for everyday essentials
their ingredients are carefully sourced
high quality and affordable they have
coffee and tea grains and oils like
olive and avocado they've got castile
soap and trash bags and essential oils
they have spices and extracts like
vanilla and almond vinegars and pastas
dishware and glassware there's so much
of public goods to make a meal including
the materials to serve it on public
goods products have great design the
aesthetic is simple and clean and there
are no garish colors they care about
health and sustainability sustainability
their products are largely free of
harmful ingredients and additives and
the ingredients are ethically sourced
and their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place it
really is an everything store
for darkhorse listeners we have the
following offer receive 15 off your
first public goods order with no minimum
purchase they're so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again that they are
giving you 15 to spend on your first
purchase
go to publicgoods.com
darkhorse or use code darkhorse at
checkout
that is p u b l i c g o o d s dot com
forward slash dark course to receive 15
off your first order
okay
yep
um pollinate a plant sustain a bee
all right that's not that great a slogan
but you know it it's it's a it's a it's
a place to start i may have mumbled yeah
you know
yeah it's been quite a week
it's been quite a week um
it's been quite a week we have been
watching um
we have been watching
with such hope and and joy what is
happening in canada uh at the same time
that we watch um
the
the media coverage of what is happening
in canada and frankly the silence is
better than
the coverage when it happens because it
is so
um
so the opposite of what's actually going
on so we're going to talk a little bit
about that but i actually i want to
start with a little bit from mila's
story i think is the is the place to
start um
i shed a lot of tears this week and i
don't i don't cry much as you know
and i'm gonna try to do this
without doing so um
when i posted uh the second thing that
i'm going to read from
a letter from
a a dark horse fan named dan
the the mother of this beautiful young
woman mila
wrote in the comments i believe that's
when i first heard of her that um
that she and her husband had been um
out on the streets as the convoy passed
last last friday
uh i guess eight days ago now
uh and passing out flyers just
single-page flyers uh about their
daughter
who
um
who's gone now
who who died of suicide
she was an extraordinary young woman who
was nowhere close to the edge before the
coveted lockdowns
and as she says um in the flyer that she
handed out
to the truckers as they passed through
their small town in ontario
i sent letters to the prime minister the
ontario premier to the federal and
provincial health ministers that the
ministers of education nobody even wrote
us back
nobody cares you can actually show my
screen here zach if you want um
this is again tara the mother of mila
speaking or writing to the truckers this
is not just about our child it is about
canada's children thank you for what
you're doing
it matters
so i say here just in the preamble to
what tara then wrote
in which she allowed me to post on
natural selections this week our
children need their world back
we have stolen some things that we can
never return
and mila as you will learn again i
encourage you to go and to read this and
to spread it widely there are a lot of
people who need to know that this is one
of the
this is one of the true human tragedies
that has resulted from the policies that
have been so insane
she was deeply loved and will be forever
missed by the many people who knew her
the truckers and their supporters and
friends are doing this for all of us and
we thank them and we thank
you the truckers who are listening um
and we encourage you as we will
throughout this this live stream today
to hold the line
and we and we see that you're doing that
um okay so if i may have my screen back
just for a moment zach will i find
just a brief excerpt from this to read
um
here from from tara mother of of milan
you can you can show my screen if you
want zack you don't need to but
my inclination
again this is
reading a mother's
grieving words
um
i guess eight months
after
her youngest daughter's death
my inclination is to spend all of my
time sharing stories of our beloved mila
with you i'd like to tell you about her
homeschooling years when we would wake
up at 0 600 hours in the morning to note
from her telling
to notes from her telling us that she
was in the forest with her bow looking
for adventures or about the novel she
wrote about wolves and barn cats when
she was only nine years old
i would love to share a coffee or two
and tell you about the 98 average she
maintained throughout high school and
the peer tutoring she offered to those
who struggled
maybe i could play you a recording of
her jazzy saxophone number or show you
the video of her playing her ukulele in
a hammock with two barn cats snoozing on
her lap
her barn cats would sit outside our door
waiting for her to leave the house so
they could follow her wherever she went
moving in great calico tumbleweeds
behind her
as much as i want to stay there in those
memories of my beloved and for those of
you watching there she is on screen at
17 with her ukulele
as much as i want to stay there in those
memories of my beloved i need to crawl
out and do this part now
the part where i tell you the story of
mila's death and the events that
precipitated it
the part where in the rubble of my life
i muster what i can to share with you
our pain in hopes that there is
something here that might make a crumb
of difference
mila illuminated and mysterious was a
creature beyond this time
she wanted to be a midwife and she would
have been a glorious one when covet hit
or part of the world ontario canada
imposed some of the most draconian and
aggressive measures of anywhere in the
world a couple of weeks to flatten the
curve right
initially like almost everywhere and
everyone we obliged
schools were closed it was near the end
of mila's grade 11 year then
there were no classes online at that
time a mad scramble ensued to get these
kids some sort of education eventually
schools tentatively opened for some we
had the option of keeping her home or
sending her in she insisted on going for
the next few months and into the fall of
her graduating year schools opened then
schools closed
then schools opened her friend group
shrunk considerably most parents abided
by the no socializing role there was
really nowhere for them to go anyway
theaters live music restaurants and even
places like bowling and the roller rink
were closed
instead the dwindling friend group that
mila was a part of had random
clandestine meetups and a friend's
frigid barn
or someone's basement
i want you
to read this entire this entire essay
but i'm going to read the last
two paragraphs
here
on the evening of may 10th 2021
i had a dream that an angel stood before
me her outstretched arms were empty and
her water-soaked wings dripped a puddle
around her feet her head was bowed i
failed
that was her message
we were awoken by the police knocking on
our door
our mila strong and true
had died of suicide
and tara shared with me also this line
drawing by an artist local to them that
is being used
as the inspiration for the stone carver
for mila's headstone
this young woman was nowhere close
to the end of her rope
before
these
before
any of this happened
and
these parents
see the trucker's convoy as the inspired
patriotic
peaceful and passionate movement that it
is
and it is being
portrayed
as hateful
as
the white supremacist as racist as
misogynistic
by
a media and governmental apparatus that
clearly does not have our interests in
mind
yeah there um
so first of all i should say
this story is um
is unbelievable and
absolutely heartbreaking in the sense
that the death of any young person is a
tragedy
there's
the potential ahead of any young person
and the loss of it is
appalling but in this particular
person's case this was
an extremely
well-adjusted girl who had a tremendous
amount to live for and
i think the thing that is so hard to
accept is how much damage was done in a
short time by a society
that i'm beginning to realize and really
this has been
this has been
what my week has been characterized by
the recognition
that you can tell how
dangerously broken our society is by the
number of different ways in which you
can see that we are absolutely failing
children and this story contains
not one but several of these and
they combine
and their combined effect is you know to
have robbed the world of somebody that i
have no doubt would have been
an utterly extraordinary adult
um and it is you know
on the one hand it's a wake-up call
right because the point is the very
definition of what a society is it's not
it's not a generation a society has to
go on in order to be legitimate there's
no construction you could put together
that wouldn't continue that would be
valid right no matter what it did in the
short term
ours doesn't really do anything right in
the short term
not anymore
and
it is also setting itself up to cease to
exist because it no longer
regards children as fundamental and
important and
in any case we're going to have to think
through how we confront this you know
what we have here is the evidence of the
failure we don't have a recipe for
fixing it
but i believe you're you're absolutely
right
in um
you know somehow this story of mila and
the story of the truckers
they both are and aren't the same story
right right
but the
misportrayal of the truckers
i mean first of all
on the one hand
that's all you need to know
right you've got
you've got
people working class people who were
months ago heralded as heroes of the
pandemic for keeping the goods
on the shelves
these people are now being demonized and
being demonized so transparently if you
just simply do any of your own work you
can find out who these people are in
fact i'm sure you're going to
talk about it but uh you know there's a
couple of journalists who are
walking around at random when what this
does is it allows you to find out the
truth of the convoy by
following somebody around i i happen to
catch a bit of the stream this morning
where he ran into people on the other
side who were protesting the convoy he
didn't run it so this is uh viva frye
yeah v-i-v-a-f-r-e-i
um youtube channel um he's um i think
he's a lawyer um
out of uh out of quebec and he's been
going to the um to ottawa to the
protests and just you know doing live
streams and i highly recommend his his
today just ended right before he started
actually just by coincidence um but yeah
he heard that there were going to be
counter protesters there today and he
sought them out he sought them out he
actively sought them out
and most of them refused to talk to him
and those who did uh were using uh
you know pat rhetoric and uh accusations
that aren't true claims claims of
violence claims
claims such as we have heard over and
over and over again but the people who
were actually walking around there both
who are or who are portraying it through
live streams and other um and um and and
we hear from many private people who
aren't out there you know publicizing
what they're seeing
they're seeing none of this and you know
are there excuse me are there are jean
provocateurs on the ground occasionally
very few maybe i but they're not even
seeing those well but
okay i want to go back and and deal with
the agent provocateur problem because
it seems to me right let's say there are
confederate flags as
bizarre as that is in canada right or
swastikas or whatever
right
it can't you cannot live in to the
extent that we understand that protest
is an important process right this is
written into the american constitutional
dna to the extent that we understand
that that process is important the idea
that all you have to do to shut it down
is transport into it something vile
capture an image where the vile thing is
present with the other thing and then
the point is well the other thing is no
longer valid because you wouldn't want
to be near a confederate flag wouldn't
would you essentially what you're doing
is you're handing power the ability to
shut down critique if you do that so we
can't do that i mean
not only that
um but
the
i mean hypocrisy is not anything close
to us a strong enough word for what is
going on here compare
i i hope someone does this formally i i
did not spend the time to compile the
comparisons
of the footage
and the
coverage of the black lives matter
protests that here in portland nightly
became riots
for months
the media coverage of this was that it
was mostly peaceful
there was actual destruction of property
all the time including actual
i was gonna say actual statues like that
matters this only matters because
one of the few things that has been said
that has any accuracy with regard to
pushback against what is happening in
ottawa is that there was desecration of
statues and as far as i've seen the
desecration of statues involves having
put flowers
on a statue i saw a sign a sign around a
statue
so
compare that to the toppling of statues
the beheading of statues you know
fake fornication with the head of
statues during the protest protests of
the of 2020
what could possibly explain
the complete inversion of the truth in
both of these cases
in both of these cases
yeah i mean and i i agree i you know
i'm pretty good with language
i know there's supposed to be a term for
what this is the
it's not even the complete
fictionalization of what's taking place
it is the exact inverse of what is
taking place exactly in in both of these
cases we're like 18 months later and
it's the exact opposite what is
happening on the ground is the exact
opposite of what is being portrayed in
the media and some number of people are
nodding along going okay
i guess it's true because i saw it on
the screen well you know because the
person who i've come to trust because i
see them on my screen all the time is
saying it to me therefore it must be
true
so
um i had a very good discussion with uh
one of my patreon groups this morning
and this this is functioning as a
reality check in sort of the way the
dark horse is functioning for a reality
check for many people this group of
folks lives all over the world actually
and you know we get to check in with
what you're seeing what i'm seeing and
you know i actually was a little bit
thrown this morning by the fact that
what you and i are seeing about this
convoy is not necessarily even what
people who agree with us on the
substance of covid are seeing so sure
how is that the case but
the
the point i want to bring out of that
conversation is the question of what
role
a suspension of disbelief is playing in
what's happening and how much of this
effectively requires
the
the viewer
to
willingly accept the fiction in order
not to
confront the reality and i'm seeing
evidence of this um
all over the place really
so i don't know what to do about it but
the fictionalization that is taking
place is and i almost never use this
word but
it's evil right this is this is our
civilization attacking itself by
blinding people to the actual facts of
their
their existence
but part of what is going on is that
there are incentives driving people to
accept the fictions because if they
looked even just
slightly outside of the screen they
would understand that what they were
being sold was nonsense right that you
know this is anything but a violent
racist protest right yeah
um
so it's it's hard of course to know
what what people do and do not think
what people are and are not seeing and i
had i had wanted to go
right into dance later but i think
actually given where we've been here
um talking a little bit about um
what the mainstream media specifically
has has said and done and and what we're
actually um seeing on the ground so um
don't show my screen here zach but
here's
um
here's
this is just out of a little country
newspaper in
ontario uh from
the a city councilor
and it's exactly in keeping with
what is in the larger outlets
the sad humor of it all a relatively
small percentage of people who have
concerns about vaccines are being used
by well-organized white supremacists who
want to break up the country probably
funded by big oil money although we
don't know because so many donations are
anonymous and who would happily take
away the freedom of the vast majority
who want to go to work visit family go
to school and go out for dinner and a
show without increased infection risk
this is fundamentally an issue of how we
keep our community safe it is not about
freedom for the few to engage in
anti-social behavior but the freedom for
most people to go about their regular
lives without undue fear we make these
decisions every day when we create laws
we have used vaccine mandates
successfully for many decades as one way
to keep society safe
actually it's not humorous white
supremacists see the kkk cross and many
depictions praising the truck convoy are
hijacking the vaccine debate for
profoundly self-interested reasons it is
destructive to the country and people's
rights to safety i'm gonna leave the
guy's name off of that because i don't
need to
to start a pile on but there's so much
wrong
with that and this is an elected
an elected official
well it's one of two things there's
really it has to be one of two things
okay that is either
a window into somebody's utterly
profound delusion yeah or it is
gaslighting
right it is it is attempting to convince
you of the inverse of reality such that
your own view of reality
will look insane yeah
um
the idea that the people
out in like
whatever it was like negative six
degrees weather today and throughout the
week are out there
trying to take away the freedom
of others oh the selfishness of those
people
cheering on working-class truckers
probably funded by big oil money no
problem so by the way this was written
before
gofundme go fund me
um
took down you know the the the gofundme
for the truckers for freedom um
movement had already collected more than
10 million canadian dollars and uh
something around a million or so had
been dispersed and then um due to claims
that appear to be completely false
um and uh and their reference to
standard um you know the sort of the
small print that they can make mean
whatever they want to
decided not to disburse any more money
um
yesterday they were saying
that you had to actually go in and
request your money back or they would
distribute it um by some other to some
other organizations and today they are
saying that they're actually going to
refund the money to people without you
having to make their quest that's so big
of them
but the idea the you know
the idea that this is white supremacist
that this is funded by big oil that this
is about people trying to tamp down
others freedoms uh that this you know
that
this white supremacist of the kkk or any
of this
just
go and look at any of these videos that
are out there and
i will read later from or actually maybe
maybe i should read now from and this is
all out of order from what i had in mind
um
here we are uh
you can show my screen zach uh this is
from a piece called a knight with the
untouchables
i'll just read the first and the last
paragraphs
and again i'll link to everything in the
show notes i live in downtown ottawa
right in the middle of the trucker
convoy protest they are literally camped
out below my bedroom window my new
neighbors moved in on friday and they
seemed determined to stay
i've read a lot about what my new
neighbors are supposedly like mostly
from reporters and columnists who write
from distant vantage points somewhere in
the media heartland of canada
apparently the people who inhabit the
patch of asphalt next to my bedroom are
white supremacists racists hate mongers
pseudo-trumpian grifters and even
kewanon style nutters i have a perfect
view down kent street the absolute
ground zero of the convoy in the morning
i see some protesters emerge from their
trucks to stretch their legs but mostly
throughout the day they remain in their
cabs honking their horns
at night i see small groups huddled in
quiet conversations in their newfound
companionship there is no honking at
night but i haven't noticed not even
once are reporters from any of canada's
news agencies walking among the trucks
to find out who these people are so last
night i decided to do just that i
introduced myself to my new neighbors
this is not someone and it goes it he
then talks about the people he meets and
this is not someone who i think was
particularly favorable to or inspired by
this this movement he lives there and he
wanted to go meet them because it was
clear to him
that what he was seeing on his window
without even having talked to them was a
mismatch for what he was hearing on the
news
and he tells his story and it's he tells
the story of the people he's met and
it's amazing and so i'm just going to
finish the last paragraph
as i finally made my way back home after
talking to dozens of truckers into the
night i realized i met someone from
every province except prince edward
island they all have a deep love for
this country they believe in it they
believe in canadians these are the
people that canada relies on to build
its infrastructure deliver its goods and
fill the ranks of its military in times
of war the overwhelming concern they
have is that the vaccine mandates are
creating an untouchable class of
canadians
they didn't make highfalutin arguments
from plato's republic lox treatises or
baghos
i don't know that
uh interpretation of westminster
parliamentary systems
instead they see their government
willing to push a class of people
outside the boundaries of society deny
them a livelihood and deny them full
membership in the most welcoming country
in the world
and they said enough
last night i learned my new neighbors
are not a monstrous faceless occupying
mob they are our moral conscience
reminding us with every blow of their
horns what we should have never
forgotten
we are not a country that makes an
untouchable class out of our citizens
so
i'm reminded of this i think i've talked
about this once before on a live stream
but i think it's worth revisiting
there's a moment in
the movie the truman show
truman is beginning to figure out that
the world is being constructed around
him uh for the purpose of misleading him
so that he will
you know
do for the cameras what is necessary for
the truman show to be successful
and as
he begins to
get wise to this there's a moment where
he takes his wife
an actress hired to play his wife but he
doesn't know it
into the car
and he starts behaving erratically
and the point is the entire premise of
the truman show depends on the fact that
he is predictable enough that they can
construct reality ahead of him before he
gets there and so he's driving around
his roundabout like a maniac because the
point is nobody knows what road he's
going to take out of there and so the
people who make the truman show happen
are freaking out because he's not doing
what he needs to do and the point is
that behavior
is necessary right you are being told
that these people are x you need to
behave unpredictably and go find out if
they are x and if they're not what does
that tell you about the truman show
you're living in yeah right that that's
the place we are and so this is this is
really the question is
if people are suspending their own
disbelief and buying this [ __ ]
all they need to do
is just flip that one bit
right you don't need to revamp your
whole
way of viewing the world what you need
to do is flip that one bit and say i am
no longer going to do my part in
accepting the story i'm just going to
spot check it yeah i'm going to see
whether the story adds up and when you
find out that every place you spot check
it it breaks through it's it's it's rice
paper thin
right then the point is okay what would
have to be true for that to be right
right if every news channel is either
not reporting the story or reporting it
upside down what does that tell me about
what those news channels are what does
it tell me about what else is on them
right right that's what that's what we
have to do yes and
you know you you you blaze through the
the gofundme issue the deeper one digs
there the crazier this is yep
right this is a 10 million dollar
campaign this organization this business
functions for this purpose and this
majorly successful campaign the business
itself has rejected it right what kind
of insanity is that right that's
cannibalizing their own business but
even worse than that right gofundme was
perfectly happy with the suspension of
the rule of law
in the chop in seattle right they
allowed that to be funded they even
heralded it right so
the point is this is a completely
arbitrary political business
seeming to function as just a you know a
conduit to deliver a service oh well i
guess i i'm going to disagree strongly
with the word arbitrary there it is
precisely not arbitrary
it is directional
the message is clear it is ideological
it is ideological it is not arbitrary
and um
and there's and there's no place
to go for most of the services
that we now imagine that we have as
citizens of
the world really um
if you don't conform
to the opinion of the ideology
that is running
all of these platforms
so
i have a little experiment planned with
with respect to this because i'm so
infuriated by you know seeing this
this business take up arms against some
fraction of its users for an ideological
purpose that is obviously despicable and
insane when they did not stand up for us
when you know the law was being
suspended in the pacific northwest like
what the hell are these people standing
for so anyway here's here's my little
experiment
my sense is
a
gofundme realized something after they
did this the despicable move to steal
that money and deliver it to charities
that they felt were acceptable as they
were slandering it's not clear to me
that they were going to make the
decision but no i don't think they were
going to make the decision but the point
is it was going to be the list of places
that they find legitimate whereas they
were declaring the convoy illegitimately
which is clearly not their right nor
anything they have expertise in yeah and
obviously they [ __ ] it up because you
know they're buying a false story about
what this convoy is
but okay so here's the here's the point
a something spoke back to them very
loudly and the reversal that you and i
both noticed that they went through
today where they went from we will
distribute this money to others to oh
actually we're going to refund it to
everybody because holy hell we just
you know revealed the the
morally bankrupt nature of our business
and suddenly our user base is in revolt
against us right
we have to go further
right yes they have to watch their their
life their life as a business flash
before their eyes so that this does not
happen again so that every business that
contemplates this remembers what
happened to gofundme when they pulled
this asinine [ __ ] in the middle of a
global emergency
so here's my proposal
and i don't know if this is going to
work but i would like it to i think we
need to learn to wield the tools at our
disposal and
one of the tools at our disposal as much
as it seems frivolous is the trending
hashtag system of twitter
and so what i'm going to suggest
is that we attempt to get our anger to
register through twitter in a way that
we can see it reflected right
and what i've done is i've put together
a an annoyed tweet
and annoyed to treat tweets it's an
annoyed tweet um and
my tweet
uh responds to their revision of their
policy where they tell us that no in
fact they are gonna refund the money
because oh go away right that thing um
and i've said sure sure
you're just simplifying the process
which is the excuse they deployed for
why they were changing course
the hashtag is go truck yourself all
right so what i want to do is i'm going
to tweet this out um
those of you who are interested in
participating in this experiment which
is i hope a lot of you you can feel free
to
support that tweet retweet it but what i
really want you to do is use the hashtag
go truck yourself with all of the words
capitalized and come up with something
that you can say
mind you there are truck emojis if you
need them
you can make a little convoy if you'd
like but uh
anyway i think go truck yourself uh is a
theme that uh
gofundme should hear loud and clear
um from those of us who are paying
attention so i'm tweeting right now go
track yourself um there is apparently um
givesendgo.com which is
maybe maybe not a christian site that is
uh sort of a gofundme with a with a
christian slant
uh where www.gibson.com
freedomconvoy2022
is supposed to be accepting um donations
now but uh every time i go there ah now
it's now it's up so
uh zach if you just show my screen
briefly
um
half the time i go there i get an error
and um sometimes it shows that it's up
and um
whenever i have tried to donate it
hasn't let me uh so you know i think
it's not i i think it doesn't have
enough bandwidth something i don't yeah
um but if if
if you donated before on the gofundme
site or if you didn't but you think this
is an honorable thing uh i i believe
that this site uh is uh if you can get
through is all right so um i want to be
a little careful because who knows you
know i don't i assume the site is on the
up and up but i know nothing about it
can i bend my screen please thank you um
but
one thing if you're looking for
something you could tweet with that
hashtag uh
a link to that site would allow
gofundme to understand that their
business was going to people who are
more honorable than they are and um we'd
give people some way that is useful to
to address this i would also point out
you know there's certain words
that are absolutely necessary to
describe what we're doing and we've
gotten the inverse words because so much
of what we think comes through this
inverse filter right
so i started using and i know i may have
picked it up from someone else but i
started using the word dissident for
those of us who have been vocally
disagreeing uh about
coveted science and public policy that
word is now caught on and i think it
matters because to understand that you
are joining the category of dissidence
you are not you know
uh
you are not forced to accept the
epithets well that that tablet article
that uh i read briefly from last week is
titled the dissidents as well so yeah
it's it's it's being used it's
definitely now the widely used term and
the dissidents themselves use it which
is good um but i would point out
the whole portrayal of this convoy as al
everything i have seen has not used the
term civil disobedience
right the whole point is i've seen it
you've seen it okay a little bit i
haven't seen it much
so i haven't seen it at all so it isn't
used being used much is what i'm
guessing
and i think the point is
civil disobedience is inherently about
violating
rules right that is its nature we
understand that this is sometimes
necessary and we can argue about whether
it is necessary in this case but the
idea that there is no that you know
because this is disruptive
that there is something wrong with that
now it has to be disrupted because you
know what else was disruptive these
mandates which actually don't make any
sense so
actually that's um
unless you were going somewhere
that's a really excellent segue um
to
in a minute zach i'm going to have you
show that video that i asked you to clip
but first i want to say i'm not going to
show these because i didn't prepare
which um but we have
um
you know there's lots happening in
canadian politics at the moment not only
is trudeau m.i.a
um
but uh the conservative party uh has um
thrown out its leadership and they've
got a new interim leader of the
conservative party candice bergen
and there's a there's a piece of footage
of her
which i will link to in the show notes
in which she proclaims that the people
protesting are passionate patriotic and
peaceful which is rather an honest
description of certainly what i've seen
and we also have a um a speech from
brian peckford which again i will link
to
he
was one of the framers of the canadian
charter of rights and freedoms which was
penned in 1981 so for you know for
americans
listening it's analogous the american
bill of rights which was ratified back
in 1791 but canadians version
happened in 1981 rather more recently
of all the first ministers who worked on
the canadian document the charter only
one remains alive today and that's
peckford
he is appalled at the coveted era
violations and
um
the code era violations of personal
freedoms and
um
sorry i'm distracted by our cat who
showed up um
he is appalled he is um being very
active in standing up against them
and he's also former premier of
newfoundland uh and in the speech that i
will link to uh he says among many other
important things as an individual you
come first the groups that you form with
come second
so this is this is critical and this is
exactly framed in the canadian charter
which again is analogous to our um
our bill of rights here in the united
states
um
and then a third inspirational speech
that i watched this week and there were
there were many more than that but
is from a corporal bullford
uh and it is i believe it is his
resignation speech from the royal
mounted canadian police where he has um
he's been a mountie for about 15 years
and i guess zach if you could show just
that 40 seconds or so of this speech now
so i'd like to read my oath of office
that i took 15 years ago
i daniel bulford
solemnly swear that i will faithfully
diligently and impartially execute and
perform the duties required of me as a
member of the royal canadian mounted
police
and will well and truly obey and perform
all lawful orders and instructions that
i receive as such without fear favor or
affection
of or toward any person so help me god
i cannot be compliant or complicit
with federal policies and provincial
regulations that i sincerely believe to
be unlawful by every measure
i cannot be compliant or complicit with
federal policies and provincial
regulations that i sincerely believe to
be unlawful by every measure
these
are the sites of people that we are
losing from public service
at the same time
that we have um
the prime minister of canada
still trudeau retweeting
this
zach if you will uh
an inclusive military is a strong
military glad that members of our
canadian forces are now able to choose
from a more inclusive list of military
ranks let's keep working to build an
institution where everyone feels welcome
this is
in the middle
of this week while there are
while ottawa is
in the middle of the most massive
peaceful protest that i can remember
ever seeing
trudeau is retweeting and the military
personnel command
of canada is tweeting the canadian armed
forces modernizes military ranks in
french where you get to choose whether
or not you want to be identified by
masculine rank or effeminate rank
depending on how you're feeling that day
presumably
so this is who is being encouraged to
remain in the service
of the state
whereas corporal bullford wilford i
think i hope i got that right
this is the second time you said it that
way
who
goes back and assesses what it is
that his oath of office requires of him
and
understands and i think correctly that
he cannot
comply
with the orders that are being handed
down to him because they are not lawful
and zach please give me my screen back
um i want to make a couple points about
this
um
first of all i think uh was it corporal
bullford yes um
what he did is extremely courageous and
he made
um
good use of the opportunity to make his
point
but i want to make a more general point
about the process
by which all of the people who are
supposed to be protecting us
are being sorted
between
the compliant
and the refusenix
and the point is
draconian mandates that you must comply
with or leave
leave a force of people who comply
the idea the this was always going to
come down to immoral orders right that's
the thing about authoritarianism is
eventually it delivers the immoral
orders and the question is do you
understand nuremberg do you understand
that you must not comply and leaving is
not necessarily the right way not to
comply because if it leaves behind a
force that is compliant from which all
of the people who think from themselves
have been purged then we have a new
problem now i don't know how to deal
with this obviously the military can
throw you out if it wants right as can
any police force but
well i don't know what happens with
unions and the like but but nonetheless
the idea
that um
we are going to
exit these positions rather than use our
position
in order to reject those immoral orders
right in other words
a police officer who is given an immoral
order to
arrest somebody who is engaged in civil
disobedience cannot comply
and that is what we should do that is
the most powerful thing we can do
with our positions uh is
is resist
and just simply not engage in it and you
know and i think
we saw this for example with the tow
truck drivers who refused to tow away
the rigs of the convoy when they were
ordered to by police i don't know this
story
that's what i understand is that there
was resistance to
doing it and i think i think the thing
is we need to start thinking in these
terms you're talking this week in ottawa
yes beginning of the week um i think we
are
we are we are not recognizing the
strategic genius
of these draconian mandates that you
either comply with or you're out
the point is to leave a force that does
not think that contains nobody who
thinks to contains nobody who has that
that resistance within them and if
everything if everything that wears a
uniform is suddenly going to be filtered
in this way
then you know what happens next right we
know what that looks like
inclusive of those who buy batshit
gender ideology and exclusive of those
who disobey unlawful orders
doesn't sound like a group of people who
are capable of defending
freedom or justice frankly right and it
happens at every level i mean we've also
in our own congress in this country
we've seen uh
almost all of the voices that you might
be inclined to listen to as honorable
have exited because
the
role of being there has been made
intolerable we've seen it in our
classrooms where the most dedicated
teachers have not 100 but in large
measure been forced to leave because
they have to do things in the classroom
that they know have nothing to do with
education and are actually
counterproductive to it
and you know it's a it's a positive
feedback that we we we have to be
we should properly be frightened of and
let me just um
yeah
we could dump on the duplicitous ken
doll all day of course but um i think we
are not not going to it's just too easy
at target um
uh but which is the
the epithet you gave him uh prime
minister trudeau last week and it um it
is it seems apt i have yet to see the
pushback that makes sense against that
as a
as a name for him um let me just say
that one of the things one of the other
things that he did on social media this
week while he's in hiding because he's
scared of truckers uh was this tweet and
you can just show it while i'm reading
it zack and then and then
and then take off my screen again please
quickly today in the house this was
february 1st today in the house members
of parliament unanimously condemned the
anti-semitism islamophobia anti-black
racism homophobia and transphobia that
we've seen on display in ottawa over the
past number of days together let's keep
working to make canada
more inclusive
so
when we speak of the uh the duplicitous
kendall we should always use the term uh
with all due respect and the amount of
respect due is zero
he's not doing any respect but
yeah um
incidentally just as long as we're here
chris martinson tweeted a video that has
trudeau's
lofty insane words overlaid over images
of the protest oh yeah this is a good
one it's it's beautiful so uh you can i
was going to link that here in the show
notes i didn't know that chris had
tweeted it but okay so anyways making
the rounds for you that's really really
good uh so just i'm sorry i interrupted
you but this is um you know actual
footage of the protests you know people
people dancing in the streets people
cleaning up about garbage people you
know people putting honorable signs
up and um and being actually inclusive
hey you know what um with the sound off
on the people and uh trudeau's uh
sycophantic
hypocritical
nasty and divisive words over over the
top yeah yes
it's quite the juxtaposition indeed put
it that way indeed uh
so i
do
will want to read some from dan's letter
but it looks like you have some place to
go first perhaps well i have a couple of
uh things that i wanted to i wanted to
cover one of them is i just wanted to
note the existence of what i think
it can't be a totally new form but
something i've now seen three times in
the space of a week or two and i wanted
to call attention to it
so there were three instances
where
something emerged online as if some
person had made a terrible
gaff
right and the three instances were
whoopi goldberg which some people will
say but she did make a terrible gaffe
actually people will say that for all
three of these things whippy goldberg's
uh statement about uh
about the nazis
there's
jordan peterson on joe rogan's program
where they talk about the terminology
black and white and the fact that it is
chromatically bizarre okay
and the third one is robert f kennedy jr
speech at the march
in which he talks about um
uh anne frank and
in all three of these cases
these people took tremendous flack and
so i think you have not explained the
third one for those who don't already
know what the story is the rfk one yeah
uh
rfk gave a speech at the march
in which he said something that actually
i think i've said here on darkhorse are
pretty close to it which was that there
is a distinction between the tyranny
that we are seeing presently and all
previous examples that i had been
prepared i'm speaking now for me i had
been prepared from childhood for the
fact that it could happen anywhere don't
kid yourself it can't happen here
because it can
what i was not prepared for at all
was that there would be nowhere to go
right that was always
written into those stories was that it
happens and you don't want to be
slow to recognize it because one of the
things you might have to do is run
and
i have been noticing now for much of you
know at least the second half of kovid
that
the places that i would have thought to
run
you can't go there in fact some of the
worst places right including including
israel
right
um canada's giving us all hope again
well canada is now telling both sides of
the story right we're seeing a rebellion
against the draconian stuff but they've
been ahead of the curve with respect to
the the draconian stuff
um so anyway the point is in all three
of these cases here's what i saw
so again this was um
this is whoopi goldberg on the view
talking about the holocaust
right and this is uh
jordan peterson and joe rogan talking
about the
naming of races by black and white as if
those are really descriptive of skin
color and you have rfk talking about um
this being different from past horrors
right and and specifically the holocaust
frank and her uh or temporarily
successful uh resistance by hiding and
uh
of on traps escaping over the alps and
things but um did he invoke the von
trapps yeah well he didn't invoke them
by name but he talked about there were
things that you know not everybody was
able to get out obviously but people did
find ways to escape right that was his
point and you can like it or you could
not like it but
here here's what i saw and actually this
there there is a precedent um
you know
which uh eric has talked about which is
the bean scream
all right so the dean scream howard dean
running for president uh at the end of a
defeat uh a night in which a primary
where he is defeated is giving a pep
rally to his supporters and he says and
we're going to go to hmm and he lifts a
bunch of states and his voice is hoarse
and he lets out some kind of a screechy
something or other and it was a total
nothing but it actually ended his
presidential bid because it was
circulated by uh the the late night
comedy programs as if it had been this
terribly embarrassing thing
anyway here's my point about these three
instances
we can go back and forth about the
details of what joe rogan and jordan
peterson said what whoopi goldberg said
what robert f kennedy jr said
um and we can talk about their merits
but
specifying exactly what they said that
was so very terrible
is not really doable in fact i haven't
heard it described anywhere right
trevor noah
uh mocked jordan peterson and joe rogan
and his point and i don't think there's
anything wrong with his point his point
was what they're saying is so obvious
why
why are they even talking about it right
whereas cnn
absolutely slandered jordan peterson
um
it's great to be at two simultaneous
places in in the pushback that are in
mutually incompatible compatible i mean
what don lemon that's so dumb you're
racist for saying it that's so obvious
why are you saying right you can't have
it both and the cnn version yeah i hope
i'm gonna get this right don lemon right
who is talking to michael eric dice and
i hope i have the person right who is
somebody that jordan peterson had a
famous debate with not here terribly
long ago
and obscured him jordan peterson
is describing michael eric dyson having
called jordan peterson an angry white
man okay
don lemon
inverts this
and reports it as if jordan peterson has
called michael eric dyson an angry white
man or something like that it doesn't
make any sense it doesn't make any sense
i mean that doesn't even i mean michael
eric dyson is not a white man that's
exactly why it would be a crazy i hope
this is true i like this i believe he
even showed the clip and then did it
it's it's it's incredible we should we
should link it in the show notes but
anyway here's my point i know it's so
unbelievable that it sounds like i must
have it wrong right yes well let's hope
i do but
but it's pretty crazy but anyway here's
here's my point about what happened yep
in all three of these cases
somebody treads on sacred ground they
talk about some topic that they maybe
don't have license to talk about why do
joe rogan and jordan peterson get to
talk about you know dark skin why does
whoopi goldberg get to talk about nazis
and jews why uh does robert f kennedy jr
get to talk about you know
jeremy right okay so the point is all
these people don't have automatic
standing because they're not members of
this group
they talk about stuff and actually all
of these people
talk about it
apparently not worried right
and then somebody's like there must be
something wrong in there i'm going to
broadcast it as if they've said
something so self-evidently wrong
that they have just jeopardized their
entire standing
and we'll see if somebody can find out
what that wrong thing is right we'll put
it out into the world as if it's
terrible and then we'll see whether
anybody can formulate the complaint
credibly right and the point is actually
even you know even in whoopi goldberg's
case
right where what she says sounds
offensive she says you know the nazis
were not engaged in racism because the
jews that they were persecuting were of
the same race now i don't subscribe to
her perspective but it's not that she
said anything about it was okay
she's just has some definition of race
that
it involves this being within rather
than between and the fact is it's tone
deaf but
it's not
evidence that she
has any animus towards some racial group
well it seems to me actually that the
thing that ties the three examples that
you've brought up together
is that the attempt to
cancel the speakers on the basis of
these supposed errors
has been in large part due to
the technique used is you're not a
member of the group you're talking about
therefore even talking about is
unacceptable
and um you know this this is a pretty
modern i think but it feels it feels
like a very modern thing you know and of
course you know we we experienced some
of this at evergreen as well like you're
not allowed
to
think about have any opinion about say
anything about anything with which you
do not have direct personal experience
furthermore you need to bow down to the
you know individual anecdotal lived
experience of anyone who does as soon as
they tell you anything
that they believe to be true about
anything about that group and you know
this this is of course incoherent at
every single level um and that's not to
that's not to say that individual
stories aren't powerful of course they
are um or that anecdote um can't sway
people or that you know what it is that
you have experienced doesn't give you a
particular perspective
that those who have not lived in your
skin cannot experience the same way but
that isn't part what we are as humans
that is part of what we do
we have theory of mind we have empathy
we have the ability to say hey
try my shoes on for a while try living
as i do try looking through my eyes here
let me help you
and this this modern thing is
i'm gonna force you not to look through
your eyes to tell this story and i'm
gonna bludgeon you with the idea that
you that my eyes exist and i have a
story to tell but i'm not even gonna
tell you that because i'm exhausted or
some [ __ ] like that you know it's
it's entirely incoherent at every level
and it's you know what it is it's it's
mean
wow it is deeply deeply
mean
at many of the individual levels and of
course it is powerful it is a powerful
way to shut people down right and that
is the thing is it is about power there
are really two versions of civilization
that we could be pursuing one was the
one that until you know
a few years ago we all thought we were
pursuing at least all the decent people
did which was the society in which
you know your background doesn't dictate
your opportunities period right it
wasn't you know the colorblind has
become a bad word because people have
misportrayed it as a you know a kind of
uh
you know pretentious claim that you
can't see color rather than it plays no
role in a courtroom or a classroom you
know
it is it is nothing more than a
phenotypic marker it's like conflating
men and women are equal under the law
with men and women are the same it is
it's the same conflict it's the same
conflation so the point is you've got
the world in which these things no
longer dictate your opportunities right
that's really the liberal dream that's
why conservatives are now defending
liberal gains is that we all you know
liberals liberals were right about this
people's kind of won this fight 30 years
ago and now they've abandoned it and the
conservatives are defending it and
there's something beautiful in the
conservatives defending i mean maybe
conservatives are always defending the
the gains of past liberals and that's
part of the confusion here but
um it seems
actually now that you say it that way
that that would have to be the case it
really has to be it would have to be the
case but but in any case um
the alternative world is one in which we
apportion special rights here's a word
that you can use that they can't use
right that's a little privilege for you
and the point is do you really think
you're going to fix the world by
apportioning privileges does that sound
good to anybody
obviously it's insane it's not stable
the right world is the one in which you
know yeah you're never perfectly gonna
get there but the one in which we
approach as well as possible a a place
in which none of the things that have
hobbled any of our ancestors still
matter right you really do you know is
meritocracy good
yes do we have one no not quite but we
merit plays a role right what you want
is a system do we want to increase the
role of merit and decrease the role of
chance and luck yes we do it is that
exactly we want a system in which merit
plays as large a role as possible and
then we all know what it is we're
supposed to do which is be meritorious
right bring good things to the world
help others bring good things into the
world right those are the things we
should be fostering rather than a system
you know does it it's it's plainly
insane on its face that you're going to
reapportion privileges in any way that
could correct for anything in any
permanent sense right that's a that's a
that's a forever game of chaos right it
couldn't be done even in principle yes
so
like that
like that indeed
um
i've got three things i want to do
before we be we sign off um
maybe let's start with um
reading a little bit from
from dan's letter
okay which i again posted on
natural selections let me give you a
little
little background
on
on this um this is
verbatim uh the text of a letter that
um
dan arkhand i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly um
just wrote to me on my patreon actually
having having just joined and wanting to
share a number of things
um
after our last live stream uh in which
we talked about the the convoy as as it
was rolling in
and
he
uh i have since received many more words
from him and they're all all amazing you
know for both both in the case of dan
here and tara who's
um
the mother of mila um
we've been in more contact since and um
i am just i am so
grateful and hopeful that these are some
of the people who are
in part leading the charge who who are
who are standing up and saying
you know not not in my name and and are
are working in their own way to hold the
line
so let's see i wanted to
see since zach is on my screen now i
have to figure out where
yeah let me just give that back to me
for a moment so i can find my notes
um
okay so again like
with mila's story i encourage you to
read this whole thing
but this um you can god i keep on
forgetting because i'm talking at the
same time the narrative of the trekkers
okay so you can give me about that back
nazak or you can give it to them again
the cavalry rolled in
on a lining for a common purpose um oh
boy um
here we go
the narrative of the truckers this is
just a piece of this letter
the narrative of the truckers was
beautiful and tragic the same people who
we all believe to take an enormous risk
to their lives in early 2020 to feed the
country during peak covert hysteria
we're now being fired for doing exactly
what they were called heroes for last
year it made no sense
now they the forlorn heroes the western
canadian cowboys were going to ride into
town and slay the dragon and all for us
it was almost too good to be true but
they were exactly the heroes we needed
and not a moment too early i still can't
believe how close we were just last week
to collapsing into the weight of our own
despair
and just like that the media turns
attention from the resistor next door
onto them
they were vilified
this was the second galvanizing moment
the stories went they weren't heroes
after all they were every iss you could
imagine there were only 12 of them no
maybe 100 tops they weren't coming the
high res were closed they were dragoons
and thieves coming to rape your
daughters in the night no seriously this
was written that every twist and turn we
secretly questioned their resolve in the
face of this ruthless onslaught
until yesterday just like you would
expect in a movie the crowds emerged our
highways and byways and it became clear
that despite the best efforts of the
naysayers and mainstream press canadians
would ignore the strange stories and
cast their lot with the convoy betting
against the narrative
waited for we waited for hours our toes
freezing sharing gloves and stories of
friends and family members being
ridiculed silenced and pushed out of
society the vast and unvaxed working
unemployed families and single people
popped up with homemade posters and
canadian flags fear had given way to
hope we were not alone
and after five hours of delays the
cavalry appeared down the highway with
flashing lights and blasting foghorns
they rolled in and rolled and rolled
literally thousands of trucks and
truckers and vans and cars with flags
and wagons and messages of hope from
across the country with bible verses of
jericho and truck trudeau flags
for nine hours straight we immersed
ourselves in the electric and timeless
moment it kept on rolling we were
transported into the biggest
cheerleading flag waving poster shaking
party you could ever want to be at we
shared moment after moment with our
heroes and with each other the names
melted away we were all very very real
we screamed and cried and hugged
strangers we filled each other's cups
and promised without words we will not
go gently into the night it was
understood implicitly that we had each
other's backs and we were completely
aligned for our common purpose our
freedom
this is only the beginning of this
moment it is not nearly over but there
is no going back i feel deeply that
canadians led by our cavalry were
dragged across the rubicon today
i so hope he's right
i so hope he's right
um
well this um
does raise a question i think it's very
hard to know what
where to even stand for an objective
view of how effective this is but i will
say
i'm watching
uh
some scary reversals of progress
but i actually take from them the
inverse of the message that one might
right i'm sorry things like italy
doing well no i mean
it's delicate because he's a good friend
but i'm watching
joe forced to second-guess himself
a little bit yeah um and
i really want him not to second-guess
himself because i think the point is the
reason that the pressure has come to him
the way it has
is that he is actually
over the target and this is the expected
flak and the point is we are i believe
much closer
to a
a victory and by victory what i mean
is a general revelation of how much we
have been misled about we are much
closer to that than we think
and that is why things look bleak at the
moment and the trucker convoy is
is worthy of this
level of slander because it is so
dangerous to the narrative and the fact
of people coming to the roads to see
them and supporting them is the evidence
of what it really is i guess the point
is the worse the slander gets
the stronger the evidence that you were
actually making a difference that power
cannot tolerate
and um
i guess i would ask as long as we're
attempting to figure out what our power
actually looks like um it is worth in
light of what joe rogan has done and how
far he has brought us in terms of
uh revealing the narrative to a huge
audience or revealing the falseness of
that narrative i would also ask people
i've been
trying to get people to realize this is
a human being
he does incredible things
but you know he's also it's it's
impossible to to endure this level of
slander and not have it get to you and
you know he's got you know some rules he
doesn't look at comments online and
things like this to immunize himself but
there's only so insulated you can be
when the world is saying terrible things
about you at a decibel level that's just
you know
your windows don't keep it up and anyway
so i would ask people i mean even the
toy poodle royals are uh coming after
him
especially toy poodles i mean yeah right
yeah um but anyway
um anyway
thanks joe rogan with all the words
capitalized has trended
i think i started it but it trended a
number of times over the last couple of
weeks
and
i believe it needs
to keep doing that and
hopefully we do not want to fall
short just shy of the target because
suddenly the resistance was so strong
that we thought it might be an infinite
distance away that's not where we are
that's not where we are the the
narrative has crumbled because it is not
high quality and because the evidence
caught up to it yeah and uh you know let
me just say i
this this phrase um
i don't even know exactly how it's
invoked but the idea that you know when
you're getting the most flack it's
indicator that you're right over the
target
has always struck me as a little
a little not right because obviously
there are a lot of ways that you can be
getting flack that don't necessarily you
know
metaphorically you can be getting a lot
of pushback when you're just wrong for
instance um or when you're over some
target that isn't the one that you think
it is perhaps um but in this case i
would say um
absolutely
absolutely is um the and it's far beyond
yeah this is a lot of flack and it's
going on for a long time
uh is is he and um
is he right over the target yeah he's
right over the target and they've
switched topics too as of today it's i
was just going to say like it's not even
one target it's like you know they're
just they're throwing they're throwing
all the flack at them and they're
they're in different it's in different
flavors and different i don't know
what to do before but the flack over the
target thing the fact that doesn't come
in flavors does it
yes
right um
the uh
the point is not that all flack
indicates target yeah it's that the
flack you are getting is flack over the
target right but that means that you
can't take getting flack as evidence
that you are right
of course and the thing is um
a honorable person will
recognize that difference but the point
is in this case this is flak over the
target what is the target it is the
coveted narrative and its bankruptcy
moral morally and analytically
and and
humanly
on every front and you know
let's put it this way
anybody who thinks joe rogan is a racist
either doesn't know the first thing
about the man or is an idiot
right but i don't i didn't know that
that's what they had switched to but i
mean it's
focusing on that is the same mistake as
focusing on they called you a racist at
evergreen well it was never what it was
about right right and that's and that's
not what this is about they'll do
anything and in fact
you know as as evergreen unfolded on us
and we saw our
careers stripped away in all of this um
i
remember saying oh my god like there was
one star and that was a lie and it's
been revealed as a lie now there's a
different story and it's also a lie but
it hasn't been revealed oh they switched
to a different one it was like one two
three four they just kept on choosing
another one because
none of them held and i think
you know we can hope and we must assume
and we must do everything we can to make
sure it is true that
the same thing happens uh with joe rogan
it's so much more important in every
regard right um that you know the the
the attempts to
de-platform to cancel to you know
destroy
um
can not
be allowed to succeed
this is exactly exactly what i'm getting
at and believe me it is uh
in part a hard-won set of insights
because of what you and i went through
we've been slandered and we've seen what
that looks like from the inside as
things that are nonsense are said about
you and uh stories are inverted to to
make you look a particular way and i
just think i mean indeed he invited you
on
so early very first week and uh
and
we i remember meeting him but when he
was he was in la still at that point and
meeting him in his studio and our boys
met him as well
and he was
so honorable such a good man
so
just courageous and stalwart and wise
and smart and human and compassionate
and all the things we have known him to
be ever since yep
he is and what people don't get because
he's a larger-than-life figure is that
he's also exactly life-size and that
that means that we have an obligation if
we want somebody to do the job that he
is doing then we have to defend it right
we have to defend it even if it's not
obvious that our
uh
position allows i mean for you and me i
guess it is because we have a
platform of a certain size but but the
point is what you do
in all of these conversations where the
slanders are being deployed
matters and anyway um
thanks joe rogan
hashtag thanks joe rogan would be great
if it uh trended now in light of this
nonsense and really every time they hurl
garbage at him uh
in order to shut down
his
uh honorable and successful exploration
of
reality on many fronts indeed
um
one last thing
before we uh before we stop here for the
week and
i will come back for those watching live
uh with our q a
um but i received
we received
uh a letter this week a handwritten
letter it's wonderful um we received a
fair bit of mail
and this
this letter has nothing to do with covid
but it has a lot to do with grief
um
the letter writer
uh
is didrik he says i'm 29 years old i
asked him if i could read some of this
i'm 29 years old from oslo norway
currently i'm doing a phd in
biotechnology where i study biological
phosphorus removal and wastewater
uh he proceeds to talk about
his extraordinary family
and the
death of his little sister a year ago
and the experience of going through the
the grief
of it and the grieving and despite
having a very tight-knit family
and a medical system that he was
actually proud of and um and felt
extraordinarily well treated by and i
know how many of us will be lucky enough
to have both of those things
at the end of life for for someone we
love deeply um
but he
he talks of not
of having been able to spend time with
the body of his loved one um of his
sister
um and but but not enough and was was
brought back to this when um
he reports i guess it was episode 91
i read an excerpt from
chapter eight of our book hunter
gatherer's guide to the 21st century on
grief
and one of the things that we say in
there is spend time with the body of
your loved one after they die
he says i had some with my sister and i
wish i had more so all of this is just
an amazing
story to have been thinking about this
week as i've been
dwelling on grief
on
the impossible loss of your own child
and um
thinking about
what else we are all grieving right now
even those of us who are lucky enough
not to have lost a child but who have
lost
all of us have lost some things these
last two years and
he says
then everything had to move on
just like it must have done for all time
but it doesn't go back to normal because
there is no going back
things went forward to normal
i've been thinking about this phrase
going forward to normal
um
you know there's been a lot said about
the new normal the old normal what is
going to be normal
and
it's never occurred to me to talk about
going forward to normal but we we are
the people who will create our own
future
and
we have to create the normal that is
acceptable to have in the world
things will go forward to the normal
that
that we make
well uh if i might i've been saying as
you know from the beginning of the
pandemic
it will never go back to normal i've
known that from the beginning
this completes it though and it's not
that it will go forward to normal it
will go forward to normal
if we
do this right
if we learn the lesson of this and we
extrapolate from it correctly and we do
what we must do
it will go forward to normal
if we fail in that
it will continue this way and we will go
from one
not normal situation to the next not
normal situation and eventually
we won't make it out right so
i think forward to normal is exactly the
correct objective
you almost invoke the hopi
uh saying we are the ones we've been
waiting for that one also belongs here
right and uh you know let us i i think
we should put everything into going
forward to normal because
there really it's going to be a short
ride if we do not accomplish that that
really it nicely encapsulates that we
have to go somewhere that we cannot
describe from here but
it must be because the alternative is
unthinkable
that's right
all right
um
rather than go through all of the things
that i usually go through at the end
i would like to
strongly encourage people to go to
naturalselections.substance.com and find
specifically those two pieces
the i have to figure out what they're
called hold on
um
the cavalry rolled in
uh written by dan
and uh mila's story written by tara
and read them and
you know comment if you like and like
them but share them i think that they
have the capacity to
to change people's minds about some of
what they think they're seeing
or to
affirm the
our shared humanity
i will say
as i said on twitter
read it read mila's story in particular
somewhere you can cry because
it's almost impossible not to be
profoundly affected by it and you should
let yourself be profoundly affected by
it and
uh
anyway it's an utterly extraordinary i
don't even want to say peace
the story is utterly
extraordinary and totally heartbreaking
i do hope people
will understand what it means and what
it demands of us
so that
this can stop
it's really very important
indeed
[Music]
so be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside and go
fund me go truck yourself
[Music]
you